and that night she sucked up and you're
like oh you're only doing it because i
said so bruv
you don't even want to do it yeah look
at your posture all right cool guys
what's up
what's up sign up to the patreon links
in the description
um yeah man all the bonus contents on
there
um weird one slight disclaimer not
disclaimer but basically just like
with the patreon one of the most common
questions we get asked is
do you have access to all of the
episodes or just the two that come out
that month guys when you sign into
patreon you have
access to everything so for that three
pound that you pay you have access to
every single episode that we've ever
recorded on there
um question everyone question every
single episode so yeah if you're one of
the ones that
binge our episodes time and time again
which i know a lot of you do which is
props
thank you very much um yeah jump in
there
binge away you've got like over a year's
worth of content on there now
um so yeah enjoy that if you're new here
guys welcome
um and yeah last but not least
uh this episode is brought to you by
manscaped
my guys manscaped so um
guys if you aren't aware manscaped are
bringing out well they've brought out
the lawn mower 3.0
you may have a big boat it's a big boy
team bro 1.0 not two points yeah this is
the third generation of the lawnmower my
guy
so um it also comes with manscaped
perfect package 3.0 which comes with
the crop preserver big man the crop
preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer
have you ever moisturized your balls
from not with that
dark it feels it glistens
it glistens it glistens bruv you've
never this whole kind of oh i don't know
if i want to get my ass
with the fan wall that when it's
glistening like that fresh
you want to you want to contort the
thing
behind your head
you feel like the bell of the ball pun
intended
so guys uh jump in there uh who has got
the
discount code for you now you can get 20
off and free shipping with the code sng
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
with the code sng unlock your confidence
and as always
use the right tools for the job with
manscape guys thank you guys
and without further ado back into the
shenanigans let's go
so the ff today so the fun fact for
today is
did you know that there are only well
this is speculation
i think there are two but according to a
lot more people there's only one country
in the world
that's named after a woman do you have
any idea what country is
one country in the world that's named
after a woman
oh
i've got a few do you think i'll get it
i don't know because you got the scuba
thing last week
i've got a few things that it might be
can i have a couple guesses yeah of
course you can
georgia no close not close but like i
can understand why you picked cool
georgia
saint lucia is it actually said lucian
alpha brain cheeky black alpha brain
um so yes saint lucia is named after the
woman
and her name was saint lucy of syracuse
it was named after her but
i said there was another one because um
if you
can guess the other one maybe the other
one yeah
because i did more research and this one
popped up
but if you just type in countries named
after a woman only one pops up
which was the solution and there's
another country
i just did a bit more digging and i
found i don't know if it's official
though that's the thing
okay so this could be an unofficial fun
fact guys
the second half
hmm i'm surprised you got this unlucky
one
gang so am i uh
the second one could be
argentina no but i can understand why
you picked that all right what is it
um it's actually ireland ireland yeah
to be fair i've always wondered why is
ireland spelt like that
it's actually ireland so it's named
after a celtic goddess of fertility
oh air land oh okay makes sense yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it's named after her
supposedly but yeah fair play
well the fun fact and a bonus unofficial
fun fact of the day that's very cool
that's very cool everyone else is named
after a male 1
fair play i've never i've never actually
even thought about why countries are
named the names that they're called
never once
that's interesting yeah i had no idea
fair play that's decent
very cool fun fact i'm surprised you got
it so well played to you as well you got
home as well
well played to you too because i didn't
know i didn't
tell you that for free i had no [ __ ]
clue um cool man so i've got my
why would you rather for you oh yes gang
gang guys make sure you're playing at
home as well
cool this is like a this is like an
interesting one okay which is just
would you rather work with all women
or all men so you have to either work
with only women or only men
wow what do i do
give me more give me more um let's say
you just have a
most common job office based job stuck
in an office
either all men women and you're the only
guy or all men
oh that is tough because they have their
pros and cons
i feel like if you work with
all women in my opinion the productivity
will be higher
in my opinion yeah yeah in my opinion
the productivity will be higher
and but there are i don't know
but also if it's all men
i know if it's all men i feel like i'm
in a prison yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm in a school
for boys yes that's that's not what i'm
here for yeah yeah i think
the fact that the fact that i'm in a
working environment with just
men will be so distracting for me oh
okay and
i think for that alone i would have to
choose women
okay but then again
i feel like there could be cons for that
because i could get distracted as well
with just working depending on where i'm
at where am i in this working am i my
ceo am i now your baseline
foundation foundation yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you work in hr or something or customer
services or something
you're just the only guy i mean it could
work you know it could work it could
work
i feel like i would have to choose one
one i think the productivity would be
higher
um i just feel like the way the thing
the way the business would be
would be run would be
a lot less egotistical and a lot more
mythology method logical methodical
methodical that's what i was looking for
um because i've worked under one two
i've worked on the two
female general managers in my career
three female general managers in my
career
um which is more than the males i think
i've worked with under
one one male 1 yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i noticed the difference bro okay
you can just see the difference working
with a working with um women as
bosses or ceos or even like colleagues
etc
they
i think it's what i said before it's not
an ego thing they just
they they just know what they're doing
not necessarily the men don't know what
they're doing either it's just a
different dynamic
it's a different environment and you can
tell with women
it's as if they work because they have
something to prove because they're women
in that position oh okay
i see we going um but it's not
necessarily that's why they're doing
that
or that's the reason why they're working
as they are working but i feel like i
get that aura i get that sense of
they can work with anyone yeah whereas
some men
clash especially um when it comes to
men general managers or like ceos or
whatever
um having to have conversations or
clashing with peers of the opposite sex
i think that's where the barrier is
because if
it's the vice versa a lot of female in
my experience anyway a lot of female
general managers or someone that's
higher up in the hierarchy don't tend to
have a lot of
clashes with men they do tend to have
more clashes with women though yeah
because again it's going to be difficult
because if i'm working with all women
they're going to be a bit more clashes
but
i think i'm still going to stick with
women yeah i think so okay cool so what
about you
uh all women 100 yeah i want the goss
true when i'm stuck in an office all day
i want the goss
you just went for the jokes outside yeah
i wanted you went deep yeah yeah
i want the juiciest ghost you know when
you're just sitting there and you just
like
and then you're just like oh um
uh i don't know just i don't know just
anything oh sharon did you hear about
what happened
and they're just like james um
what's up did you hear about when they
called it on saturday
hey little what is that you know how
nicole called him sick on friday
was she [ __ ] thumb and just like
shut up
[Laughter]
tell me all shut your filthy little trap
give me all the juice
was she [ __ ] and you know when they do
that um
you know when they do that like um that
pretend
whisper thing you know so so women do
this like thing when they're trying to
goss but it's like a whisper but it's
like got more bass than their normal
voice and they're like
they speak like nasally like that you're
like
sign shane was like yeah
bring up a tiny bit yeah justify it
bring you up and then they're just like
and then just level you up ah shut your
mouth yeah
you didn't hear from me you didn't hear
me just to let you know donnie you
didn't you didn't hear it from me
bro i'll be i love gossip in the office
my office is that's why i miss my office
sometimes
gossip in there gossip up in there
gossip that's juice
gossip to be there's gossip galore oh i
bet gossip galore yours is probably more
exciting than mine
because yours is like who's [ __ ] who
and all this stuff mine's just like
who didn't clean out the fridge when it
was their turn
but i still i live for it i love gossip
of the day men and got [ __ ]
read it i was a bit like what boring
would you rather
but then when i thought about us like oh
okay cool you're actually thinking when
you actually take time to think about i
thought okay you can get interesting
yeah you went deep with it for sure for
sure
um but like speaking of work
um obviously you know i learned about
work all the time all of a sudden
do you ever this is this is relates to
the the thirty things turning thirty
thing okay
okay do you ever just like
obviously with the stresses of working
or everything like that do you ever just
look
at someone do you ever just look at
someone
um who has like a completely mundane job
and just think you don't know how good
you've got it
there's a guy that works in greg's yeah
that i go to sometimes on my lunch break
yeah and i wear like a you know got the
akatsuki mask
yes he loves it every single time i go
in there
he says he loves it he asked me where i
got it from yeah i tell him where i got
it from
and then he forgets and then he'll ask
me again
but he's just in there and he's just
like cool cool cook so they've got this
like barrier thing now because the covey
they've got this like glass barrier
so they don't just take it and scan it
or whatever yeah you have to lay it all
out
and then um you have to lay it all out
and then he'll
just see which one is which and okay and
pump it through family you put it all in
there
and he's there's like oh you're right
buddy yeah yeah oh okay oh chicken and
bacon club
did it uh sausage robe yep and just
i'm thinking son of a [ __ ] bro i'm i'm
dying
where i'm at yeah you're living lavishly
you're living lavish
and then you just you just said he was
like oh dan can you get some more pizza
slices he's like
yep and just goes to the oven just pops
oh yeah they're ready
and i'm like ah you bastard
you're living good your life is so chill
yeah but just like giving man sandwiches
every day would you
would you trade places if i could afford
to
i've literally thought i think i might
have said that i've said this i had a
conversation with my brother a few
months ago
and literally um because i've told you
like we had the conversation about like
when would you quit your job kind of
thing
and like you'd quit like when you
when you're like secure secure secure
and i'd quit
as soon as i have the penny to do it
yeah yeah and then
i thought about as soon as i make the
penny
i'm done yeah that day i know you are
and i thought like oh
like what if i could quit and just do a
part-time job instead of because the
whole time i've been waiting like ah
i need to make enough money so i can
quit and do this full-time
but then i thought oh well in the
meantime what if i could just quit and
do a part-time job
because i still quitting and then i
thought oh what part-time job would i
want to do
and then i'll send you to my brother
about and i was like ah if i could just
work in subway
and you'd just be chill like who
complains in subway do you know what i
mean
i think you'll be surprised you because
i work in hospitality
i know for a fact how okay i'll give you
scenario right
yeah let's say you're working let's say
you are working in subway yeah and
it's a saturday oh yeah i don't want to
work saturdays
you've already stressed me out you've
already stressed me out
there we go it's a saturday because
you've gone from an office-based job to
a
hospitality-based job right yeah yeah
yeah yeah and with hospitality based
jobs obviously your people facing
yeah yeah whereas obviously you you
you're more on the phone nowadays right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so your people
facing
your also have to bear in mind that
people people are [ __ ]
people [ __ ] are all just regardless
so you never know
who's gonna walk into your store it's a
saturday for example um there's meant to
be three of you on one of them call sick
so there's two of you on now saturday
peak um it's sunny up it's sunny outside
as well
yeah um you've got you're on a busy
let's say you're on dean's game
busy street sunny sunny sunny you've got
hendus galore you've got mandem out for
drinks you got everyone out right
and subway isn't a massive isn't a
massive store in terms of size
tiny in terms of like the conglomerate
yeah
subway's small you've got a queue now
obviously
if there's two of you you're taking the
order filling it all up and stuff
and giving it to my man that's like the
cashier but if there's only you and
there's 10 people waiting
fam you're stressed you're stressed
already and
that that alone would probably take you
an hour
minimum to do and the queue's yes it's
gonna go down but you're gonna get more
people in the queue and there's only two
of you
are you sure you were to work there yeah
true you've [ __ ] ruined it for me
that was my dream as well you've ruined
it because i know worst case scenarios
in hospitality
yeah that sounds like a [ __ ] i don't
walk out that day i'll walk out of that
day
my apron's coming off my hat's coming
off and i'm walking out and i'll join
the back of the queue
because i'm hungry
and this is how i know i would probably
find that obviously a lot easier than
you
because of what i do now do you know
what i mean so for example when you said
um
how the greg's guy has got it good so
for me for example
we've got people called runners or buses
yeah yeah
in hospitality in general so they all
they tend to do is um
take food to the table yeah um take food
off the table and like
end of end of night jobs like cleaning
up a few things
make sure the cutlery's done for the
next day all those kind of things yeah
and obviously i overseas stuff like that
and i know what they have to do i know
their job role
i would swap my job for their job in a
heartbeat if
if it was one of those ones where i'm in
a viable position too i can afford it
it's so easy like when you've done so
much more
doing the little things that you started
off doing becoming pissed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean so
a lot of people that do complain at the
lower level have no idea how easy
they've got it
oh bro no idea 100 i know you only
it's only as traumatic as the time
you're in as well exactly i've been in
situations where not where i currently
work now
um where there's been floods in a
restaurant
there's been um sewage problems in a
restaurant and i've been the manager on
duty and i've had to deal with it
no i'm not do you know what i mean i'm
not dealing with that you have to
orchestrate and organize who needs to
come in
who needs to come and clean this [ __ ] up
how are we going to sort out every
um reservation yeah we're going to put
them speak to the chefs
speak to the ceo i'm not the ceo but i
speak to like the managing director
speak to the [ __ ] person the
contractors coming in to look at the
sewage
speak to all the um bartenders and
servers and whatever
to let them know you're gonna have to be
doing this this this from this time fam
it's
not easy that's long it's not easy yeah
i'm not doing that
um i'm telling you you're not going to
work in subway okay cool
i'm telling you maybe okay i'd work in
subway but i'd want to work in like
loughborough just like or just like a
random little village in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere yeah where i get like seven
customers a day
even on a saturday do you know what i
mean
yeah but then those ones are the worst
because in my opinion
those ones are the worst because you get
a lot of online orders because subway's
on like ubereats delivery
yes it is now isn't it all right okay
scrap the subway i think you should
scrap hospitality g i don't know if you
know what you're in for if you go into
hospitality all right because worst case
scenario
in hospitality is literally worst case
scenario
i know i'll quit i know you i know
you're quick all right but
right cool maybe let's try something
else so not hospitality
what about a part-time job working as
what about i work as like a krispy kreme
delivery driver
okay so you go from the main factory to
i go from main factory to
tesco's okay to the sainsbury's to
the main little krispy kreme outlets
that they have i just dropped them all
off and
i'm on my my good way and you're doing
that part-time
yeah my assumption is
with that job it's gonna be early hour
job because you're a delivery man yeah
probably like
four or five in the morning o'clock
you're a delivery man and you're
probably going to have
a radius of two neighboring cities
yeah you've not thought about this you
were just thinking
when you give me scenarios i think about
these yeah okay
[Laughter]
let me think let me think so what
about
what's an easy [ __ ] job what's an
easy [ __ ] job bro
you tell me what about hmm i don't want
to work to deadlines
i want to work part-time and have a
chill job i don't want to wake up at
four o'clock in the morning
to be fair i did think about going back
to personal training
okay the company that i left that i used
to manage the northampton branch yeah
they have part-time i remember
um but just as i was leaving they
introduced part-time pts
who work like between 15 and 24 hours a
week dependent
um they had the easiest
[ __ ] job i've ever seen what was it
and i remember just just getting annoyed
yeah at them
when they come in they just literally
come in because you don't have to you
don't have to deal with getting new
clients
you don't have to do because you work
for the company the company owns the
clients
but has the clients and you just train
them okay
so when i was manager there they just
introduced like literally my last month
that just
introduced um
[Music]
what did we call it they just introduced
the
part-time pt's because before that
everyone was full-time
just introduced the part-time pt's and
they'd come in a couple of days a week
for a few sessions because the thing
with pt in
it's so decent similar to podcasting
it's so decent for the first few hours
for the first few sessions
first session second session maybe even
third session in a row
is like fun and you you've got a good
banter with the clients and all this
stuff you're high energy
fam when you've been doing it four five
six seven
hours in a row you you
you'd you'd cut yourself together bro
it's horrible
damn i used to work when i was working
there full time my shift would start at
five uh no no no my first yeah i'd
my first session would be six o'clock in
the morning yeah yeah
i'd have a session from six till seven
seven no it was six to six fifties fifty
minute sessions and you got ten minutes
to reorganize the whole gym to get your
[ __ ] together yeah yeah yeah so the
whole studio
needs to be sorted by the time the next
people go six to six fifty seven to
seven fifty
um eight to eight fifty nine to nine
fifty
ten to ten fifty eleven to eleven
fifty then you break until
four then it's four to
four fifty five five fifty six six to
six
fifty seven eight
and last session was uh
at eight yeah so eight to eight fifty so
so i would start yeah so my first
session would be at six my last session
would
finish at 9 00 p.m and that was monday
to friday and then i used to work
saturdays
6 7 8
9 10 finish at 11.
so five hours on a saturday the
part-timers would come in no
do they never even used to come in first
thing in the morning either
they come in kind of like mid-morning or
mid-afternoon yeah yeah so
their sessions would start like nine so
they do a 9
10 11 bounce maybe coming the next day
do a four five six bounce
bro just stroll in and stroll out okay
then have all the best interactions with
the clients and then [ __ ] off high
energy always
i enjoy you always and then you'll be
blessed and they get paid by the hour
and pt's make money by the hour
okay i can't seem to find any holes in
that so i feel like that would be the
best thing for you that specifically i
think would work for me
plus it's in my area of expertise um
and yeah i'm good with people in short
bouts of time yeah so that would work
perfectly for me there you go i feel
like perfectly so maybe i'll look in
that
but that company is pretty much the only
company i've ever heard of that hire
pts part-time for a company that already
has
clients okay if you want to be a pt
usually you need to build your own club
of course of course
when i've done that road and that's a
grind there ain't no part-time in it
that's a grind i ain't doing that you're
working for months without any making
any money
damn when i first started pt
no money damn no money for months and
then i started pt
that drug dealer guy do you remember
yeah that always bought nando's every
day or something you ate nanos every day
yeah yeah
and he would pay me 350 pound a week
in cash no every two weeks 350 every two
weeks in cash
best client but then you wouldn't see
him for three months you get him for
like three months yeah
every two weeks like my bills are paid
yeah yeah yeah i mean
perfect yeah his name was daniel every
two weeks 350 350
350. i was like gang yeah he's literally
supplementing so much of my income
yeah he's and then the rest of the
clients obviously the rest of the
clients but bro
350 353 and then you're
you're gassed and then all of a sudden
you don't see him he don't answer his
phone you don't reply to text nothing
you don't see him
he'll come back in a [ __ ] cast he
came back in the cast in his arm and i
was like bro what's happening
man told me he was running away from the
police no he said his boy was driving
his car they got into a police chase and
his boy smashed his car into a tree
that's why his arms broke no that's just
the life these men live
wow and i was like cool so he's like
yeah we're just gonna have to work
around this
[ __ ] hour and it'll be another couple
months of good living and then he'd do
something else get
locked for a couple of months or
something go pen for a bit see that's
as good as it sounds there's a lot more
than a lot of cons with that fan a lot
of cons with that it was
a grind and then the other clients you
sign them up the worst ones you sign
them up for like ten
sessions they're like cool here's two
three hundred pound for ten sessions
yeah yeah
cool and then my only one rule was
if you don't tell me with 24 hours
notice i'm charging you anyway you lose
the session
so they'd always stick to that but
these sessions would take forever to get
through because they're
they're supposed to be doing three a
week yeah yeah yeah but it turns into
two a week
one week they're going on holiday for a
week one week they're [ __ ] kids sick
so they can't come in
and it's been two three weeks ain't done
a session and they'd always be feel too
bad
because i'd try to introduce her we need
to use these up in this amount of time
yeah yeah yeah
and you do it and then it's just big
when they're [ __ ] um but my kids got
carved and i can't
yeah do it and it's like fine like it's
fine
and you want to be a nice guy but bro
it's just like those 10 sessions would
take
months so these might not pay me i spent
that
yeah that's 300 pound i gave me spent
that yeah it's done said i've not got to
pay now i'm just training you for free
free now yeah damn i'm not getting money
from you again
and because it's so staggered just to
get through these ten sessions because
it took you so long to get through these
ten sessions
you're not seeing any results yeah and
because you ain't seen no results you're
not paying me again she's gone
she's down she's like it's ain't working
for me and she's done
bro being a self-employed pt is a
[ __ ] nightmare
i rate anyone who can do it it's the
game though
yeah i did for like four or five years
and it was a [ __ ] grind
that's a different kind of graph ma'am
oh it was any anything commission based
is a different kind of graft
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it does
test it does it does it does it does it
does
and then you're competing with other pts
in the gym as well in the same gaff
that's a lot bro bro it was
it was heated in there it was heated the
testosterone was heated
up it was long so yeah working for that
company was decent and obviously the
hours were ridiculous and i hated it
but if i was a part-timer i would have
been there for 10 years if i could
afford to be a part-timer the whole time
i would have been there for years it's
the best thing ever maybe you can look
into that jeep
i might look into i don't know if
they'll take me back you never know
management different things no i was
like hey don't mind about the management
firm me and the ceo has had a bit of
the the the owners of the company i
remember when i was leaving
so when i was leaving i handed him my
nose yeah and i was like bro
um here's your four week notice i'm out
and he was like cool he came one of them
came back to me so it's two brothers
who own this company right you told me
about this one yeah is this the same
place that didn't have
they didn't have satin fam they didn't
have nothing they didn't have um what do
you would call it
um they didn't have hr they didn't have
this they didn't have hr they didn't
have uh what's the
uh what's the thing they didn't have a
pension scheme that's the one yeah
that's illegal brother yeah yeah anyway
um
they were nice guys until you crossed
them they took [ __ ] personal it was all
business with them yeah until something
that they didn't like yeah it's like a
[ __ ] personal brand okay
so i remember emailing them like guys
really sorry i've lost my time here i
was there for a couple years
yeah i love my time here but it's time
for me to move on etc etc etc
uh give him a four week notice one of
them emailed me back and said hold
up wait a minute let me put that to you
you'll notice it's three months
big man and i said swear he sent me my
contract again
i said your notice is three months is it
every month you've worked there every
year you've worked there as a month kind
of thing
no it's just three months off the bat as
soon as you pass your probation
as soon as you pass your three-month
probation you're you're there for three
months
oh wow and i said big man i took it to
heart
well no not even i took it to heart i
basically said to them
big man no offense um obviously we've
had a good relationship the time i'm
here
uh if i go back to my new job and tell
them
i'm not i can't start for three months
i'm they're gonna pull my offer
like i'm never gonna get a job with a
three months notice yeah of course they
come back and basically said that's your
business
and i was like i bet well you either
change it to a month out of goodwill
yeah or i promise you the next three
months are gonna be hell
i basically said that i said in the
nicest way possible i said do you really
want me
working here three months against my
will it's basically is that the
situation you want to have
yeah when i'm just interacting with
clients like i manage this [ __ ] yeah i
i talk to everyone yeah so you can even
let me go after a month and i'll do the
best job i can for the next month
or i'm stuck here for three months
against my will the ball's in your court
mm-hmm and then came back all right all
right
you got your mom and i was like cool
cool i'm glad we're seeing eye to eye
[Laughter]
this is i don't know i don't like when
you guys bring this side out of me
i don't like being this person i don't
like being this person why do you do
this
why do you bring this out of me i don't
want to be that guy yeah but you forced
my hand
yeah yeah um so they were like all right
bet
so all the clients were upset et cetera
such as that i was leaving and then one
of them asked me like oh
have the owners asked you to stay and i
was like
nah they never once asked me to stay and
then he was like [ __ ] that so one of the
owners came to do a site visit one day
and it was me one client who'd rocked up
super early for no reason just to have a
chat with me
in the whole building me one of the
owners and this client
awkward there's silence in there and
then the owner's just doing his checks
and stuff like that and then
my client's like uh mark so the owners
called mark in it he's like mark um
let me ask you a question jason's been
here for a couple years here
he's like yeah he's like he's done a
good job now he's like yeah yeah he's
good job yeah he's like we love him here
like he's like
as all the clients love him all this
stuff another
the boss goes yeah ask me anything he's
like
have you asked him to stay he's like
what he's like
have you offered him a raise have you
asked him to stay have you asked him why
he's leaving
and he's like while i'm standing there
that's awkward the boss goes
let me ask you a little story when i was
a teenager
i broke up with i was with this girl um
she's really good looking and i decided
to break up with her
and when i broke up with her she said i
was making the biggest mistake of my
life
i would never find another girl like her
fast forward
10 years i own this company i'm pretty
sure she works in tesco or something
whilst you were there moral of the story
is you're missing out
is what he's basically saying fam
mostly especially i'm making the biggest
mistake possible and i'm going to end up
as [ __ ] all
so why would he ask me to stay
wow what did the client say bro the
client was
jaw dropped i would be gobsmacked i
would be
gob smacked while i'm standing there you
know he's got bravado
bravado femme that's chest that's chess
oh
bro if the client was in there i would
have and he tried to say that to me man
it would have been a fight i just swear
two years of my life i gave to you man
you know
waking up at 4 o'clock in the morning
working till 10 o'clock at night oh
those were the days you were shoveling
ice off your car in it yeah fam scraping
ice off my car
the building didn't even have heat like
central heating cars because it was like
a
renovated uh like warehouse kind of
thing so it looked fancy in there
didn't even have central heating in
their cars it was freezing in the winter
freezing in the winter bro and boiling
in the summer no
it was a nightmare it's like a metal box
bruv
which it looks sick inside but like the
actual dynamics of it
it's [ __ ] cold in the winter and i
have to wear
shorts and a t-shirt fam because that's
your uniform whatever shorts and a
t-shirt
i'm freeze i could i didn't feel my toes
for days
brav i gave this man everything and then
all my analysis did you ask him to stay
a man gave some [ __ ] [ __ ] analogy
minding him say yes when he said let me
tell you
let me tell you a little story about
this girlfriend i was 17.
wow from then i was like
oh i'm gonna blow up on you man
i'm gonna blow up on you man and i'll
probably come back here as a client
yeah and i'm making demands
i'm making unsightly demands
you prick wow bro i remember thinking
what the [ __ ] did i do to you bro this
is
business arrogance this is business bro
i'm moving to a company that are gonna
give me less hours and more money yeah
what do you want from me man why why are
you chucking it like that
basically saying i ain't gonna be [ __ ]
arrogance man arrogant
arrogant these men were arrogant so much
of a story if i replied back there as a
part-time
pt i don't know how well it would go
moral story fair enough i don't know how
well it would go
after looking for another gig then [ __ ]
it up i'll say
i'll see what they're saying in the
subway no chris scooting driver no
no yeah no part-time pt no subway no
krispy kreme
wow i don't know where we're i don't
know where we're at i don't know what to
do
we'll cross that bridge and when it
comes to it guys 30 for 30.
you know what it is um if you have any
suggestions
i'm all is i'm all is
because he needs it i need it bro i need
to quit and run oh that's jokes
um all right let's play one's got a goal
yeah one's gotta go let's do it
uh you guys you know the drill each week
i pick a topic for james
and he's got four options and yeah he
has to pick one that's gotta go like i
said guys you can always play at home
and this week's is random actually i
don't know if you can see them
um we've got random topics today or
random discussions today
so let's go um where's the pen i'm gonna
use
this one so yeah this one is random
jimmy so all these ones are
yeah yeah yeah absolutely random okay
one's got to go first one
you've got tiktok instagram youtube
patreon
bro just before you start should we just
turn this off yeah what the [ __ ] is
going on with this fridge
oh we'll leave it for now if it starts
making noise again we'll just unplug it
this fridge is doing bits i don't know
what's going on
just switch it off from the is it that's
plugged in behind you behind me
yeah yeah
cool cool i can breathe
look at it right sorry um start again
one's gotta go
tick-tock instagram youtube patreon i
actually don't know which one you're
going to pick
tick tock instagram youtube or patreon
this isn't inclusive of my own living
habits at the minute is it oh yeah
it's yes of course it is oh well
obviously patreon can't go
but then again without youtube there is
no patreon
tick tock we made our we made our our
lives work on tick tock
i know ninety percent of our fan base is
from tick tock i know and the next one
is instagram
yeah [ __ ] instagram's gonna have to go
that's how that's where
everything's at damn
to be fair just before you move on yeah
i was thinking this the other day i
actually think tick tock is probably the
best app i've ever seen it's crazy in it
it's gone from me thinking it's the most
childish stupid [ __ ] in the world
to actually when you get deep into the
algorithm bro
tip top i learned so much on tiktok you
learn everything on tick tock
and once it figures because it figures
your [ __ ] out quick quickly yeah
so you can't if you don't like a video
don't watch it
because it will start putting it in your
[ __ ] yeah yeah like you have to skip
yeah um but bro once it clocks it i had
it in the sweet spot a few weeks ago
yeah i think i've told me
yeah i had anime cooking yeah
and sutton else i can't even remember
but it was banging
it was banging and i was just like
artistic because the best thing of all
time yeah tigger is the best thing of
all time
and anyone could you see creatives on
there anyone can make it
on tick tock tick tock's legit i think
they're worth a hundred
billion something like that something
stupid like that
100 billion what they're worth 100
billion worth yeah yeah dollars
oh [ __ ] yeah that doesn't surprise me
tick tock's a serious business
fun fact it originated in china i think
yeah it did yeah yeah it's still outside
yeah it's still owned by china yeah it's
called titan house over there though is
it yeah
it's called i read it what did you say
um anyway uh one's gotta go netflix
amazon disney plus crunchyroll
amazon prime or amazon is a compromise
no private all right i just didn't type
i didn't write prime cool
prime netflix crunchyroll or what
uh disney plus disney plus uh disney
plus can [ __ ] off yeah
this plus is the most overrated platform
there is
why bro because it's good for two things
nostalgia or marvel spin-offs
yeah it's either you watch the classic
[ __ ] that you grew up on
or you re-watch all the current disney
movies that you watched in the last five
years
or it comes like your one divisions and
your
um mandalorians and all that stuff but
if you're not a die-hard star trek fan
or a marvel fan they're nothing on there
for you
it doesn't appeal to everyone um it's
just there for nostalgia
just to watch aladdin that you watched
when you were a kid it's also early in
its first year true
yeah obviously i can only go from what
it is now but i'm sure it's gonna do
great things but at the minute
like i don't give a [ __ ] i really don't
give a [ __ ] about missing plus at the
minute cool fair enough i just wanted to
know
um bulbasaur charmander
squirtle pikachu oh my god bulbasaur
charmander
squirtle pikachu pikachu
this is tough one i think i'm gonna go
bulbasaur why
i don't know i'm just thinking about
their final forms okay and venusaur's
the most trash
like god pokemon okay it's sick but in
comparison to blast voice and charizard
nah it doesn't stand up raichu is kind
of trash too
but pikachu is obviously fair enough
okay
all right this one one's gotta go
gym fresh trim
yeah a beard or new clothes
slash shoes like new gums in general
gym fresh trim a beard new glams
wow that's probably the hardest one
you've ever
put to me i'm not even joking clearly we
found out the hard way the beard can't
go
yeah yeah um
for you guys who aren't on patreon um we
did a patreon episode a little while ago
and we tried that no beard filter didn't
go well it did not go away didn't go
well
face is a mess it didn't go well um
jim can't go found that out the hard way
um
i'm tempted to say new gums you know i'm
just gonna suggest that for you or not
suggest i was going to circle that
yeah but that's i don't want to walk
around tatty but yeah new guys might
have to go
gums all right all right the last one so
in this case in this scenario
you sleep and wake up and you miss the
day right okay
so christmas day yeah your birthday
new year's eve valentine's day so you
sleep and you miss that day
for for the rest of your life okay
valentine's day valentine's day yeah 100
intentionally
i knew you're gonna pick that i knew
you're gonna pick that
all right one's gotta go tik tok youtube
patreon wow
i think you would probably pick
which is oh actually i don't know what
you're gonna pick but if i had to choose
i would probably go for that one
i'm gonna have to pick i don't that's
wow that's really hard that's really
hard bro
you'll probably never think i'd say this
but i'm actually going to say patreon
this time
i picked youtube it was going to be
youtube initially it was going to be
youtube
but in terms of
in terms of i'm i'm doing it from a
consumer's perspective as well yeah
so you can't grow on patreon yeah
patreon's for your fans yeah yeah and
your fans need that place
but patreon is just um patreon can be
replaced by something else yeah you can
always make a place of
you can always make a home yeah like
well how they say like
like without your family your house
isn't just a house and until you get
your family in there then it's a home
yeah that's like patreon like
patreon is just a place but once our
fans come over there it's a home
and it's a little community and it's
sick yeah but if
the house fell down we'll just move to
another house whereas youtube is like a
city
it's like a country the same with tick
tock
it's just like tick tock is basically
like an international
networking system yeah and it's just
quick fire like dude it's like instant
messages like yeah yeah yeah and a tick
tock you can become an overnight success
yeah and it's just like tick tock is the
place where
people who have nothing can all their
dreams can come true yeah
same with youtube but youtube's a lot
harder of course a lot harder
whereas like youtube is just like this
infrastructure that is just like
solid as [ __ ] yeah and like it's hard to
grow on youtube
but you can do it and once you do do it
you get
the rewards you deserve do you know what
i mean of course whereas patreon like i
said is just
if everything crumbled move on to the
next house build another house
move in there fair enough i like that
analogy um okay one's gotta go
netflix amazon prime crunchyroll
netflix amazon prime crunchyroll
amazon prime i knew you were going to
pick that one yeah amazon prime has only
started to pop for me like the last
couple months it's only recent yeah
hidden gems on there
there are there are um charmander
squirtle pikachu
on this one pikachu okay yeah [ __ ] his
legacy
charmander squirrel are big boys in the
game [ __ ] his legacy
all right gym fresh trim or the beard
one's got to go
that's tough in it
i'm thinking for myself i'm gonna have
to say on this one
because it's it's dangerously apparent
that the beard can't go now
after that filter thing we did it's
dangerously apparent the beard can never
go
so you gotta go fresh trim fresh trim
because at the very
least i can be that husky guy yeah and
i'll whatever i lose out on the hair i
have to double up in the gym
double up in the gym the bigger you are
the nappier hair's allowed to be
fair enough g all right one's got a goal
christmas day
birthday new year's eve
new year's eve okay cool i was gonna say
remember you sleep and wake up or you
don't yesterday completely
cool cool last round one's gotta go
tik tok or youtube
[ __ ] you now
on this one unfortunately i'm gonna say
tik tok okay
youtube is just the [ __ ] but i've
learned i learned how to edit on youtube
yeah i literally learned from beginning
to end on youtube for free
um true like it's ridiculous yeah
there's so much more you can
learn from youtube then you can oh yeah
yeah tig talks educational but at like
45 seconds at a time yeah
like youtube you have to do a lot more
research after finding out what you need
to find out on tick tock yeah yeah yeah
exactly tick tock gives opens the door
for you but you have to you have to do
all your
do it
you can get like a degrees worth of
information from youtube facts
cool good choice uh well smart choice i
should say uh one's got a goal netflix
crunchyroll
netflix crunchyroll
crunchyroll oh i'm surprised i thought
you would pick
netflix yeah mainly because netflix is
slowly but surely
up in their anime game as well they are
and crunchyroll's just anime
um it's just anime if i had if i was
stuck with just crunchyroll forever i'd
be having a great time but it's just
like
sometimes the man just wants to watch a
movie yeah yeah fair enough
all right charmander squirtle
uh
ah on this one squad i was gonna have to
go
so you're gonna go charmander for the
final yeah bro i like charmander a lot
okay
uh jim or the beard
the beard has to go you know the beard
yeah the beard has to go the beard has
to go
unfortunately i can be wham but butters
wham but buzz good lord all right
all right uh last but not least
christmas day or your birthday one's
gotta go
christmas day on my birthday uh you ever
have christmas again or you never have
your birthday again
for the sake of everyone else i'd say
i'd lose my birthday
i love my birthday but yeah for sake of
everyone else i'll i'll lose my birthday
so this is what it looks like to your
final answers he's got youtube
netflix charmander the gym
and christmas okay so it looks like
very cool yeah ma'am yeah yeah man
that's this week's one got to go guys
hope you had fun
i love you guys let us know what you
guys got and uh
throw us some some input yeah man since
my dms are open
if you have guys one wanna make any
suggestions for me
okay slide them in my way and then we
can play all right man let's finish off
with a juicy
am i the oh let's go ask hole
so hello guys huge fan of the podcast i
literally listen to it
every night while i'm working so i have
a dilemma
with my mental state okay i'm in a
relationship with my girlfriend
and i'm a huge attention stroke
affectionate type of person
and sometimes my girl doesn't really
give me much attention
i might ask her for wanting to ask her
to give me more attention
i feel odd if i do because i don't want
her to be uncomfortable or do too much
and then she's just doing it for me i
know that feeling
i don't think you're an answer for
asking for more attention but
i think it just depends on how you ask
for this attention i i wouldn't go up to
my goal and be like
babes you're not giving more attention
enough attention i want more attention
it's
i think it depends on the wording and
i'm
[ __ ] i'm sorry and i don't also think
um i don't also think you're an [ __ ]
for
for requiring attention you know it's
it's a a relationship is
it's two streaks you know two streets
yeah yeah it should be a give-and-take
i think i think it also starts i think
it depends on your definition of
attention
like i used to date a girl who thought i
wasn't paying attention to her if i sat
on a different sofa in the living room
okay yeah that makes a lot of sense you
used to [ __ ] piss me off that that
does make a lot of sense because
it yeah the definition of attention is
so key because like you said for example
sitting on a different sofa
she thinks she might think i'm not
paying attention but
i can tell reel off almost 10 different
random facts about you because i do pay
attention yeah i pay attention i know
exactly what you ate
every meal for the last one what you
liking what you dislike i know the
things that you
might not even think i know that i do
know you know so yeah it does
determine the definition of attention
yeah yeah yeah
but if you're talking about just like
conversation or in terms of like
her being around you because you said
attention slash affection right
yeah attention satisfaction maybe i'm
assuming it's like the closeness he
wants like more time
yeah yeah yeah yeah like oh baby blah
blah blah yeah
he he's that he's that don't know when
they're in bed he artists his back yeah
yeah he goes back again he pushes his
back
he's small but you love a good small
spoon and she doesn't give you that
it's long i've uh i understand him we do
understand that but again it does depend
on your
definition of attention which james did
clearly point out which is a great point
um but i still don't think you're
well with with your definition of
attention you might be an [ __ ]
if it's that definition saying now
you're on two different sofas yeah if
you're just
needy yeah then it's it's you may be an
[ __ ] i would
i would probably suggest finding out
what she um
what finding out like what we said about
the love languages and that yeah find
out what her love languages are
and it might give you an understanding
of oh okay will she appreciate
these things like she considers these
things affection
which i do not consider their infection
but if she have considers affection i
can see
why she treats me the way she does
because she's probably thinking she's
affectionate
on the other hand maybe she doesn't like
you that much bro
and then you need to find out maybe
maybe you're just meet to her maybe just
need to have a conversation
maybe she's done with this um i don't
feel like
i don't think like it obviously can't be
resolved by us it's something that you
actually have to discuss with her
yeah there's intricacies to this boy
yeah there are there are a lot of
intricacies to this so it's one of those
ones where you have to first of all
define what the attention is that you're
looking for and relay that on one relay
that to her
and have an open discussion about it if
she's your missus like you should be
comfortable enough to have
these kind of conversations it's not
she's not a random person yeah bro
i know but the thing is as well i do
understand where he's coming from when
he mine when man said like
um i don't want to bring it up to her
because then she starts doing it i know
she's only doing it yeah bro
yeah oh that's the worst i get that but
that's why i said it's all about the
wording
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah babes
you're not paying me enough tension i
would like more attention
yeah yeah it depends on the wording and
how you go about the conversation
because it has like i said it's a give
and take thing she has to be
you have to give something back as well
for for it to for it to work for for
some balance
yeah man it's just one of them ones it's
true gee like yeah
i know them once like it's oh bro yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know that ones man because
it's like is that where the ones where
it's like oh
my god doesn't really give me that much
brains and then you bring it up to her
you're like oh
like you don't really give me that much
brains like you don't
you don't don't give me head that much
and she's like oh
is it and you're like yeah yeah i'd like
a little bit more
and she's like oh that's fine and that
night she sucked up and you're like
oh you're only doing it because i said
so bruv you don't even want to do it
yeah
look at your posture
look at your posture i can't even
imagine what the posture would be
that's hilarious look at your posture
but bro yeah so i understand his
reluctance to bring it up but yeah
definitely you gotta like
wake said you gotta do the wording brav
yeah it's all about the world so i would
dig into her just make it make
make it seem like it's all about her
like you're just trying to find out what
how to make her happier yeah and then
you'll get an understanding of what
she's really about
and if tutu's like it turns out that
like
she loves being smothered with attention
then you could be like big man
she must not like me then yeah because
she loves all these touchy feet she
loves this and this and this but she
doesn't give me
any of that yeah yeah then you can be
like big man then you could have a
serious conversation and a black bro if
that's what you like
why like why the [ __ ] am i just chilling
here not getting the love
i'm in bed my back is arched and i'm
here no spooned
cold cold my arched
i want that oh yeah you're giving me
nothing back to back
oh that's cold from it's dread back to
back in bed is like
such a love-hate thing
why it's annoying because unless i'm in
bed with a girl right
and in the initial going to bed with a
girl
like you cut it in like i'm big spoon
she's small yeah yeah yeah
and it lasts for about 5 10 15 however
long you can last until your arm [ __ ]
hurts
and i want to turn around because i just
i'm more comfortable yeah more time
sleeping
without touching anyone yeah yeah i make
sure
that she knows it's not beefing i'm not
turning around because i don't want to
yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause i feel more comfortable yeah so i
kind of turn around and i put my arm so
i can
you do this rub your foot on your legs
so she's like yeah
babes i'm still here i still fancy you
yeah yeah
i really don't know if it will but best
of luck best of luck guys thank you very
much
yeah guys we love you